we're all on time today we're all on
time we're all on time everybody oh my
god this is so exciting it is not that
rare of a thing we're not we're very
prompt but we were very eager for one of
us to be late we were we were excited we
were like giddy about oh glenn's in the
office but he's not in the room yeah
we're going to get him it's going to
happen again there's not going to be 180
of these things right i mean something
like that yeah it's i will never be late
again
you think so
i can guarantee it okay oh
there's got to be a small part of you
that's regretting making that close you
can't actually you can't actually
guarantee it
however well of course not can you
guarantee
that's the business that's the building
then
jeff lewini
i'll say uh
i'm i'm stalking hello oh
oh yeah no do it
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
continue continue yeah no sorry they
would have to be a bad accent because
you don't want them to know where you're
from
that's why that's right
that's why it's about that that's why
it's a bad accident hello uh uh uh i'm
stalking you with glenn howard
there's two of you
why is there a child on this call i'm
not a child
[Music]
guys
this episode is fantastic
i'm very happy with i'm very pleased
with our show not this podcast i'm glad
that you're enjoying the uh the episodes
dennis and dee go on welfare i feel like
we're really hitting our stride with the
show at this point now yeah i would
agree with you i i think
this one and
the one just before the gang goes jihad
are sort of really strong examples of
where we were headed with this show i
mean it's it's one of the first with
with the gang goes on welfare uh
yeah it really starts to feel like the
show in in many ways to me there were
aspects of this episode that i felt
though we were leaning too hard into
displaying that these characters are
awful people
like like that yes what do you mean
oh like the bathroom scene yes like the
bathroom scene but see okay so one of
the things i will say you're not totally
wrong about that because it's it is very
very despicable one of the things that i
really like about that is that it it
it's the it's that first taste of like
the characters just being
so completely and totally oblivious not
only oblivious to their behavior but
actually thinking that they're the
opposite you know what i mean like you
guys are literally saying like we're
good guys i'm a good guy we're good guys
we're good people we're get you know and
then you just spray here in the face
you're not doing it on purpose i can't
but you're oblivious to the fact that
you've done that yeah i i don't mind it
like um in terms of what we're going for
i just felt like the execution was like
it's like two on the nose like that that
it's like two
i i obviously i hear you but i can't
tell you how many times i posted
something i think i talked about in the
last two podcasts ago where i said
something to the effect of somebody said
to me that they don't like my sh they
don't like the show my shows talk about
mythicquest and sunny because they can't
tell who the good people are and who the
bad people are you tell me about it
because it's hilarious okay so i just i
posted that on on twitter and it got
like a massive response which was great
because it was generally from the people
who like you know the people who follow
you on twitter the people who like your
shows and and yet there were a lot of a
lot of people like maybe thousands of
people who were saying things like i
didn't get sunny at first until i
understood what you were doing now to us
it was like so obvious we felt like we
were making it so obvious from the very
beginning but i think it takes a little
getting used to and i think episodes
like this where you're like it's so
we lean into it so heavily that these
people are so cruel
to the point where like i think my
favorite
part of the episode which is so on the
nose
is when
frank says i don't he's talking to the
quote unquote slaves and says wait a
second you don't drink you work hard how
did you get into the position you're in
she tries to
hold on honey and then turns around i'm
like okay i feel like at this point what
we're we're basically saying exactly
what the show is well and it might be a
little heavy-handed but i think maybe
that in mind so much that that joke i
feel like is a little more subtle there
was just like one or two where i was
like all right this is we're leaning so
hard into it but look overall i love the
episode from
these are little things but from a
production value standpoint i really
love the episode like having
dennis and dee on that stoop in philly
the scene where they go to buy crack
that that street the how how
authentically philly those scenes are
half the episode was shot in philly yeah
look at how many scenes were shot yeah
exterior philly and it's a little bit of
a disservice to the show when we don't
do that but
you know it got more difficult as we had
kids in fact what do you mean we do do
that
um right
right we do
oh sorry yeah you guys do it this was
the first episode i remember pitching it
to uh f fx this was the first time i
remember pitching this
where they where they uh
said um
i we don't know about this really what
was there
even in the first season where we
changed we talked about this already
where we changed the um
they were still into the storyline this
one when i remembered very distinctly
being in venice
at the apartment that you and i shared
in venice uh not italy venice uh
california yeah muscle bee home of
muscle beach um and i pitched it to nick
grad who's the our executive and i said
i think we're gonna get dennis and dee
addicted to crack he was like nah man no
you guys you can't do that and i'm like
well no let me explain to you why and
then i explained to him why and he's
like well now you definitely can't do it
and we were i was like no no we're going
to do it we're going to do it and he's
like i don't think you should do it and
then we wound up writing the script and
it was and it just worked and it was so
funny and they let us do it i mean i've
talked to numerous people who said early
on you know like i'm talking about like
when we were in season five or six or
seven
and uh they were telling me
my buddies and i are super into the show
i started watching it and i showed them
the show and then they got into it i
would always ask what episode did you
show them
to get them into the show and
more often than not it was this episode
it was the gang goes on welfare um i'm
i'm not totally sure why it must have
been something
that episode i think was the first
episode to really strike a chord with
people and and hook people well how
about how about this like right in the
very beginning dennis and dee say we
have dreams we're going to go pursue
them and here's how we're going to go do
it and then dee says i'm going to sign
us up for unemployment benefits right
and then dennis and and just like no no
come on let's go we're going to follow
our dreams and then you find out that
you're getting 400 a week that's more
than you made at the bar right
so this is literally something that the
country is struggling with right now
that the minimum wage is so low and the
cost of living is so high and that right
now even though that we're coming out of
the pandemic people don't want to go
back to work because their unemployment
benefits are higher than the minimum
wage yeah so this is literally something
that we're still continuing to struggle
with yeah and the and this and the [ __ ]
that they're talking about later when
maria starts to try to explain it to
frank and frank doesn't want to hear it
is like exactly what the show is right
right right it's it's a shame too
because i thought we'd solved it
i thought we'd solved it we solved it on
sunny yeah you know what we do you know
what i think we did saw did we solve the
korea such no we didn't did we damn it
we haven't saw have we solved that he
died
the guy died
there's no way but they're still in it
there's still a new one in there
i feel like uh there's always going to
be another this was the first time we
nailed we really nailed going to the
title
where the going to the title is is such
a good joke don't worry about us we're
gonna be just fine being destined to go
welfare yeah like that was the first
time we really i remember you telling me
jimmy simpson reached out to you and
told and told you that and like said
that he like laughed out loud i remember
you telling me that and being like
that's a high bar yeah yeah jimmy yeah
jimmy is a tough critic for a comedy i
remember he like reached out to you and
said that
that's great
that's awesome and the guest cast is so
good yeah yeah like all the guest cast
is so good in this episode
the woman who played the woman at the
welfare store aisha hines aisha
hindsight
is great yeah
uh every time she pops up in something i
get excited she's such a great actress
um yeah she's she's great in the episode
i love how real she played our my
favorite thing when our is when our
guest cast comes in it just plays
a very real grounded person that is
encountering
maniacs and can still make it funny and
can still make it funny yeah and and
there are very few actors weirdly that
can do that they can play it straight
play it real play it grounded and yet
what and understand that what's funny
about it is their reaction to the
insanity that's being displayed in front
of them and you know it's it's so funny
because you know a lot of comic actors
want to come in and like make it funny
and it's like no no no no it will be
funny if you just react honestly to the
insanity that's that you're you know
that you're witnessing
yeah but it helps if you're a person
whose honest reaction looks funny yeah
you know like like like there's a
version of that same
woman who who plays that part and does
it totally honestly but doesn't it
it ain't funny and yet aisha's
performance is very very funny it's
knowing how long to pause before you
react to the line and it's all yeah it's
like the timing well like her reaction
to um her reaction to dee grabbing the
pen
is is very it's very real very funny and
you know that was i don't think that was
a scripted moment i think it just
happened and she reacted that way
because she's funny here's the thing
that stood out to me so when we asked
for the book of of people's images and
it's called a facebook yeah yeah did we
invent this book no
what no it had already been invented but
we didn't know about i certainly did not
know that i'd never heard of facebook at
that time so that was a purely that had
nothing to do with facebook for me no it
had to do with a facebook yes that's how
they came up with the book of faces
that's how they came up with the name of
the company that's right right right so
we were using it the way that people
traditionally have been using that word
and so did zuck
zuck yeah zuck yeah but i think we might
have some legal recourse here if we take
this scene
to a court of law and say hey we had it
first
we might have some winklevoss kind of
wiggle yeah
i would say that probably the second
the second uh or maybe maybe third most
popular meme from our show
comes from this particular episode the
bismarcky stoop
no
no okay really can you can you guess
well maybe i'm not mean i could be wrong
i could be wrong but i will you guys in
the top hats yeah i've seen that a lot
you guys in the top right yeah crying oh
yeah yeah yeah
crying at the at the end
yeah yeah i have seen that pop up quite
a few times
there's the shots of the pats and gino's
famous uh steak cheesesteak philly
cheesesteak places um never again after
season two right we had a little bit of
it in season one and season two seeing
those locations and then we're like nah
after that i don't know i don't think
maybe we went back
or maybe not can i can i confess
something to you guys go ahead oh god
i've never had a cheesesteak yeah yeah
i've never had we know from anywhere now
yeah what do you mean what is it the
nitrates what's what's what's holding
your nitrates
i don't know what a nitrate is i'll be
honest i don't know what that is
delicious
it's deliciousness yeah um no at the
time well when we were going to philly a
lot like in those early seasons um and
and we were near those uh steak place uh
steak sandwich what are they called you
weren't
oh yeah yeah you guys i did them okay
let's talk about that let's get into it
i did the master cleanse biggest mistake
in my life what a what an absolute gut
destroyer that was yeah it's just awful
an awful experience through and through
and i wish i hadn't done it anyone's
thinking about doing the master cleanse
which is the lemon don't get sued don't
get sued by the master
oh the master um yeah
it's the lemon uh god what is it paprika
it's not i don't know it's starving
yourself it's lemon it's it's it's hot
hot powder and and hot and honey honey
no no maple syrup maple syrup and yeah
yeah paprika and you just eat that all
day long
eat it
uh and uh it's awful and it absolutely
destroyed my uh my intestines for about
a year um
i also lost way too much weight and
looked so skinny in season two because i
did it right but i think i did it while
we were writing season two which was
also just torture yeah yeah torture i oh
god just don't do the master i heard
somebody saying they were gonna do the
master cleanse the other day and i'm
like what year is it we played we played
a like a baseball game like uh a group
of us for i think was my bachelor party
yes it was and was was i on the cleanse
you were on the cleanse and we did like
shirts and skins
or something with the teams and when you
popped your shirt off we did shirts
skins and bones like
it was like playing baseball with a
skeleton
i was concerned
but she bounced back writing that into a
whole episode didn't we yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah you kept the miracle
episode
you were insisting that you felt great
you said you did yeah no but i did i
actually did great no no but i would go
through periods of extreme euphoria uh
on that on that let's call it a diet um
there were certain times of the day
where i was really hungry like in the
morning and
like afternoon evening
i wasn't hallucinating uh it did sustain
i mean it does sustain you like in a
weird way uh you know and and i mean i'm
telling you like i think anyone who's
fasted for a long period of time can
tell you like there there's like periods
of ex like real euphoria i mean
uh so in a way i did actually feel
amazing um there was it was only that's
your body's defense mechanism to make
dying not as bad
it's like it's like let's let's
[ __ ] i'm dying all right give the guy
some euphoria before this is all over
yeah um yeah
maybe making him okay if we give him a
little euphoria he'll think that living
is good and he'll eat something yeah
right right life's worth living remember
how fun living was i do i do remember
the very first thing i had was like a
handful of like just a couple of like
almonds
i had like a couple of almonds like when
i was coming because you have to ease
yourself off of it i did it for 10 days
and you orgasm i know i mean i i
literally got so high off those almonds
it was absolutely insane and then i had
like vegetable broth after that and i
was so [ __ ] high off of that it was
it was unreal man it was incredible
oh guys don't ever do it don't do it
there's no reason for it we segued into
that or not i don't know we were talking
about something that i actually wanted
to talk about and then you know yeah but
that's just you were saying you never
had a cheesesteak oh that's that's what
i never had a cheesesteak yeah well at
the time at the time it was because i i
wasn't eating red meat i didn't eat red
meat for a very long time like for like
i don't know 13 14 years yeah we know
well yes but this isn't for you you
[ __ ] idiot you said guys i have to
make an i have to make no i said guys i
have to make an effect confession i've
never had a cheese steak yeah to me and
charlie you're saying that to me in
charge i've never told you guys that
i've never had a cheese how do you know
in the last i started eating red meat
again like seven or eight years ago how
the [ __ ] do you know i haven't had a
cheesesteak between now and then i can i
can surmise based on knowing you for the
last 17 years
these are acting like you've never seen
me eat like a breakfast burrito or a big
pasta dish or like french fries i eat
that [ __ ] all the time that's true
you're back on it and it's encouraging
to see it's encouraging that's true but
i can i can see the thing i can still
guess if you if you laid out 10 things
if you laid out 10 things like 10 [ __ ]
foods yeah okay and i can and i know
that you do eat some [ __ ] food from time
to time i bet you i could pick out which
[ __ ] food you did eat and which you
didn't what's scary about rob is i feel
like he knows [ __ ] about you or me
better than we know about ourselves like
he's like he's like he's spying on us in
a way like he's
you notice things that maybe the other
person get off me you creep
jesus
christ he's creeping on us all day long
i didn't realize you were so creepy how
did i not realize this until just now
you're so creepy
you're a creepy guy
name a junk foot dog we'll come up with
a list
yeah i know you know what i bet i i will
to give you credit i i would i would i
would guess that you'd probably be right
nine out of ten times the things that i
would have versus the things that i
wouldn't have you know based on
conversations we've had and you seeing
my food preferences and certain things
where i'm like ooh
you know that's kind of gross and that
where's this salad from a meal delivery
service yes mcdonald's cheeseburger no
like some things are very cheeseburger
from a certain kind of restaurant yes
right oh cheeseburger from another kind
of restaurant no no no
no and that's i think most people eat
food yeah and really not
right yeah but you know it's
yeah whatever i uh guess
this it hit the nerve
no no no no
no no no it's just you know i i just
don't
i don't like being portrayed as somebody
who like literally never eats delicious
food
i i i don't like it no but you are more
exacting and particular about your food
that's true than most people oh without
a doubt without a doubt no i i try to
follow like it's like the
90 10 rule 90 of the time i eat
extremely healthy and i don't eat for
joy at all and don't really particularly
enjoy what i'm eating
i eat it purely for health reasons and
then the other 10 of the time i kind of
eat whatever the [ __ ] i want and i i i
think it's pretty good look my doctor
says my numbers look good
you guys
i'm gonna live forever 90 of the time
it's gonna be miserable but i'm gonna
live forever but ten percent of the time
you'll enjoy it you'll enjoy ten percent
of your life and well and by the way
that ten percent that i'm eating
whatever the [ __ ] i want guarantee you i
enjoy it most more than most people
because i've deprived myself the other
90 percent of the time
yeah maybe why don't you get it down to
like 60 40. then you can enjoy 40 of
your life but then my numbers are going
to go down not necessarily my numbers
are fine hey whatever the [ __ ] i want
i bet your numbers well well but i go to
a real doctor
yes you go to a doctor somewhere who who
tests for things that don't even exist
wrong
wrong
i go to i go to a western medicine guy a
western medicine compare numbers that's
what we should do
that's what we should do let's grab our
sheets let's grab our graphs and our
charts and let's compare our blood urine
and feces you will have to go to a
neutral source right
third party
i don't trust glenn's doctor whether he
says it's western or not oh you think
he's working
you think he's working the numbers like
i got west of west west of highland
boulevard
you definitely
go far enough west if you go far enough
west you'll definitely up in the east
keys
[Music]
guys let's talk about the vig
uh do you guys know what a vic hold on i
i
charlie your character doesn't know what
a vig is do you know what a vegan to
this day i i don't know you don't
totally know what a veg is forgotten
i think maybe around the time we did the
episode we learned it understood it and
then i you know that that goes under
deleted files right we were all still
watching the sopranos at the time so
that was fresh in our heads yeah yeah
what is it again it's it's the interest
that you pay the interest that you're
paying on the show the loan you've taken
vigorous yeah so you you buy it's short
for what vigorous now that i didn't know
yeah it's
vigorous goomba word yeah you you borrow
money from somebody on the street like a
gangster figure shut the [ __ ] up it's
not short for vigorous do we have a fact
check megan
i'm gonna give you a loan it's gonna be
a bit vigorous
what's the victory what's the licorice
yeah and then you pay and then usually
it's like uh 10 points which is like 10
and then you don't have to pay back the
cap you don't have to pay back the
principal you just have to pay back the
tempo you borrow a hundred dollars and
each week you could pay back 10. oh
and but that's on time because you stay
on top well so the thing is just
interest it's just interest that's all
it is sort of i mean i guess it's
different from interest in so far as
it's not on the up and up
figurish
vigorous
nice work how did you know that
gangster stuff i'm into gangster stuff
oh yeah about all that [ __ ] what do you
mean like uh you already read books
about like the the mind i'm literally in
the middle of
uh in the middle of another gangster
book i just love it i don't know why
it's like a fascinating subject to me
you should make a gangster show
there's so many good ones that have
already been done i can't do it are you
allowed to make a gangster show yeah
yeah what do you mean like you could do
an island
gangster shows irish gangsters no you
couldn't could you do a show about the
italian mom
yeah yeah well no no i don't know i
don't know i don't think you could
yeah i don't know i don't even think you
can do that what you just did
i'm italian i can do it no you can't do
it yes i am 25
no half can't take my [ __ ] family
heritage away from me he's trying to
take your haircut he's trying to take my
hairs away and we've we've stopped that
we've stopped
saying
you guys uh charlie people charlie's
last name day uh i believe was
originally del giorno yeah don't dig up
my grandfather
i'm serious though it really it really
was that that sounded like a joke
because it sounds like it sounds like
the kind of pizza you would have in your
freezer
but this was your actual family last
name del giorno yeah uh charlie i
thought you were 25 italian yeah you're
right
uh i'm 25 jewish so
there you go
so i can drop a hard j whenever i want i
think i think
um another iconic moment from this show
that comes up a lot is us singing
bismarcky rest in peace
um
on the show now i remember very
distinctly uh when i first heard that
song when i was in elementary school and
it blew my mind it was fantastic i had
never heard anything like that in my
entire life i guess
i don't know that anything anything even
close to that had ever been done before
like it was like a it was like a pop
song
but also rap
and also it felt like he had a speech
impediment you know well he probably did
maybe it was one of the first times
that a mainstream audience was being
introduced to someone who was sort of
half wrapping half singing yeah half
wrapping half singing and and in a very
pop songy kind of way yeah yeah it was
very unique it's a great song it's a
great [ __ ] song it holds up and uh
and that's why we put it in the show
well i i like that uh you were singing
it you guys were on the same page and
then it's very stereotypically our show
where you were then giving her notes you
were telling me that she was a little
too high yeah right like like the
characters can't just like you can't
just do it yeah you can't just do it oh
you mean as the characters yeah as the
characters oh yeah maybe also in real
life but he was playing as the character
i remember us getting in a really stupid
fight
here we go here we go charlie said don't
call him fights
he said call him well was it a fight or
was it a creative disagreement i don't
know it was it was a creative argument
it was a creative argument um do you
guys remember uh let me see if i could
tee you guys up for this so there's a
moment where
uh dee and i are waking up after binging
on crack by the way i don't know why we
were so strung out on two rocks of crack
cocaine it makes no sense but whatever
let's move past that um anyway we're
super strung out
and uh we wake up in the morning and the
alarm clock goes off
do you remember the argument that we had
about the alarm clock going off yeah
you do i think so okay before i say i
think so yeah i'm not going to say with
certainty but i do believe i do you
remember what it was i would would say
it's got something to do with the
with
my
i could be way off i feel like maybe rob
and i liked the idea of putting that
rooster and the ring yes and the
hawaiian song in there
and you did it
okay no what i liked was i wanted the
hawaiian song
and either the rooster or the alarm
sound but not both i was like i'm cool
with the rooster
and the hawaiian music i'm cool with the
alarm going off and the rooster i'm
sorry the alarm going off and the
hawaiian song what made no sense to me
was a ruth the rooster and the alarm
clock sound because there's no alarm
clock in the world that you can set to
rooster and bell
let's fact check that let's fact that
megan you want to show her we can find
something no this would be in 2006 so
it's got to
be from
2 000 that's not an argument that's a
creative disagreement and i it's funny
to look back on that and be like god
that doesn't matter at all no no no no
it doesn't it does some of these
arguments move the needle that one does
not i got a surprise for you guys
uh that um well i was waiting for it to
be surprised but it might just be fun to
expose it here on you guys i'm not gonna
lie i'm very excited right now a
surprise yeah
um
we have an episode this year i'm not
gonna give anything away but our
characters wake up
together after a very long hard night if
you recall the episode that we shot
maybe four weeks ago uh-huh
i saw a cut of the episode as to charlie
we gave notes yeah and then i had an
idea and so i asked the editor
to put in i said can you go back we did
an episode dennis and dee go on welfare
don't you dare uh keep putting the
rooster in there you put in the rest of
the alarm clock
so let's
my gut instinct on hearing you pitch
that is that
i'll i'll feel as though i'll be more on
glenn's side at this moment
where in the denison is there a rooster
where's the rooster coming from there's
no rooster
the rooster you could chalk up to score
well that's like a score that's the
argument it'll be
this is the argument we were having we
were saying maybe it's score maybe it's
not source because by the way why would
how about this because this doesn't even
make any sense why would you set an
alarm clock score is music not sound
effects no it could be whatever [ __ ] you
it could be a terrible record
we should just wake up by the way no we
do we've done swooshes we've done we've
done we've done yeah
a gong is an instrument that's only used
traditionally
you don't want to get it done you gotta
use the gun but i'll go you one further
it does it actually has to be score in
the episode it doesn't makes in the in
in denison d go in welfare it doesn't
make any sense why would you guys set an
alarm clock to go off at four o'clock in
the afternoon you would have set it off
you would have set it to go off at nine
a.m so that you didn't over over
oversleep no that's not score that's a
mistake
because there's an actual alarm bell
that we are waking up to ring ring ring
ring ring and a line but you could also
you guys are like well let's put it on
like let's add five other funny [ __ ]
noises in there to make it even funnier
you could chalk it up to
meant to wake up at uh you know uh 6 a.m
i would make the argument that sometimes
things don't have to be logical they
have to be like
visceral they just have to make you feel
something and if it like if the feel of
it works then great it works and like
the logic of it uh you know that's for
someone else to decide
okay we do we do that all the time where
we're like well at this time this feels
so broad to me and you're like
[ __ ] yesterday we just you know
i know no there's no yeah there's no no
there's no no it's either funny or
facebook it's either funny or it isn't
to us and that's that's all it is
um
like there was a scene i think it's
coming up
and uh we'll get this episode where
mac is constantly stopping the door
that um barbara is trying to shut on him
yeah and rob i remember you and i in the
mix building out
the sound of like we basically said like
there's a there's like a
doorbell and maybe some jingle bells on
a wreath or something on the store which
you never see
but we layered in so many sounds because
we're like it just doesn't have
the you wanted it to have the impact
yeah of him stopping the door you wanted
this him stopping the door to feel more
harsh and strange yeah and like yeah
it's the same uh instinct that everybody
has
every [ __ ] television show and movie
that's ever been made over the last
hundred years when somebody's sipping
through a stroke oh god that drives me
crazy there that you hear the ice sound
everything every single time you hear
like the end of the end of the drink no
matter where they are in the drink it's
yup and i'm like the [ __ ] the
drink is fine because you just wanted
some life and sound to it and then the
other one is the is the one that we have
fought against yet we still have used it
because it's effective is the [ __ ]
feedback from a microphone like as if no
one's ever used a microphone ever in
their lives they have no idea there's
always you don't know what you're doing
when you s when you put when you uh you
know
get up close to a microphone it will it
will apparently it will go
yeah
only if you don't know what you're doing
they're like oh oh god they go they go
up to the microphone
yeah oh i didn't i have never i don't
know how to use a microphone
it's not that i don't know how to use it
it's that the microphone doesn't know
how to use itself right or no it's man
vs technology and and that that there's
comedy in the disconnect
you know
that we're not robots so if you want to
really get into the nuts and bolts why
this still works
[Music]
so in the in this episode guys uh dee is
her plan is to go to new york
to be on broadway she wants to be a
broadway actress right
and um you know so we've established
earlier on that she's a struggling actor
why what are you guys looking at each
other i like that charlie scratch's
beard that sounded good oh yeah it did
sound good it sounded like
i don't have that can you do it again
can you get a little closer to the mic
i feel like that's an asmr
totally yeah
scratching his beard you can make a
fortune out of that yeah i don't know
why but yeah i don't want to attract
that group no no what is what's going on
with those people i don't know uh
oh god so weird um you guys were both uh
struggling actors at one point as was i
barely i don't know if i ever really
struggled i don't think either one well
what did you you just came out hot you
you were never struggling the second i
got an agent i started working working
and i have not stopped okay when so was
there a time before you had an agent yes
yeah like i worked on the upper east
side for about 33 weeks
at rathbones yeah i worked there but i
also worked on the cornelia street cafe
i also answered phones so there was
there was a year of grinding well so
that so okay a year so what was the
weird like were there did you do
something did we have some weird jobs
yeah yeah i answered phone for the
motown digital anthology
i didn't want to use what so you know
this is this is brand new you really
i've never heard this before so you
remember how um oh oh you would call in
to buy the anthology so some guy put all
his money into this motown thing yeah
and he you know paid for the ad space
that plays at midnight and he had about
50 people in there answering phones
and you know he was making a big to-do
out of it's like all right here we go
this is it the phones are gonna be
ringing off the hook any minute the ads
are going live in three
two
one
silence
dead silence maybe like
like one phony is that me no that's over
there
maybe i answered 10 calls in a
by the way we worked all through the
night like uh until i think it was like
you know
yeah till sunrise almost and uh maybe i
answered ten calls the guy lost his
shirt we did it for like
five different nights
and i didn't want to use my real name i
don't know it felt sad to me so i was
just like hey this is chuck thanks for
calling order the remote down digital
anthology how can i help you most half
the time it was just people just wanted
to talk it was so oh
so that was a funny gig speaking of uh
i'm so happy to hear that a new story
for you brand new story yeah i've never
heard that book okay cool yeah yeah well
the good news is it'll be new for me
again in three weeks okay you know i
don't delete files as quickly as charlie
does but i do delete them yeah hey i've
ever told you about the time that i
answered phones with the motown
digitally oh [ __ ] here we go
that's great um
charlie i got a question for you you
hate it when people call you chuck or
are you okay with that yeah a lot of my
college buddies do they call you chuck
yeah okay because i kind of like chuck i
i never call you chuck because i think
there are some charlies who don't like
to be called chuck chaz chaz i like that
one we call you chazz all the time yeah
charles i call you charles a lot
yeah so it was one year in new york of
you know really just day jobs and not
working and then any other weird ones
uh you know it was funny um
i got paid to play piano in a play
oh and uh
it was uh the play was that suny
purchased the college and i had a friend
who was a student there
uh cheryl bowers she's been on the show
and uh she's married to josh
driscoretter yeah so uh she's also been
on ap bio did you guys know that cheryl
bowers plays my character's mother on ap
bio no cause you don't watch the show go
ahead yeah no so um
she was doing a play and her last
semester at suny purchase and uh she
said hey we need someone
who can play the piano and can act can
you come and do an audition and i really
wasn't playing the piano that much at
the time so i went up there and i kind
of faked some stuff
and uh did you wear a funny little hat i
don't think so and i got the gig and the
and the woman paid me to do that and uh
i commuted up there and then i like
would write some like little songs for
the play and then i was also i had lines
in the play and i remember her pulling
me aside and she'd be like you know you
really should consider going into this
music thing
and i was like ah yeah well i think i'm
kind of gonna do the acting thing and
she's like man but i don't know yeah i
wouldn't get the acting stuff i wouldn't
it's like yeah all right well we'll see
we'll see
i'll show you i'll show you all
uh that was exactly the kind of you know
what's funny because that is the kind of
thing where
you know a certain type of person gets
that feedback
and goes oh [ __ ] yeah maybe i shouldn't
maybe i'm right another kind of person
goes i'll show them
i'll show them yeah and they all show
them categories yeah and i do think that
that that that is that for whatever
reason when when your reaction to
something is is that like it i think it
can it can really fuel success right
because you you just you plow through
rejection you're just like they just
don't get it they just don't get it
somebody's gonna get it yeah somebody's
gonna get it one day yeah
i think and then uh directing beanie
baby addiction downtown yeah like uh
which we talked about i believe on the
show so uh you know and then yeah
working at restaurants so
cobbling together money wherever i could
we were a waiter
i was a
guest i no i was a busboy at raspberry
rathbones here's another story man okay
so i was working at rathbones it was uh
what holiday st patrick's day
and lots of cops firemen you know that
kind of thing um
so i'm working i
i'm there at 4am i'm opening the joint
right
and we're packed
wall-to-wall you know 4 a.m
not we're not packed at 4am but as soon
as as soon as it gets going okay the
place is back
yeah no i'm opening i'm hosing down mats
i'm i'm getting the place ready
so
so i'm i'm barb back in
all day and then the guy who comes in
for the second shift calls in
sick or whatever so i do a double so i
work 4 a.m to 4 a.m and i close like
close up right
uh these these these guys who are
bartending were making money hand over
fist i mean it the place was packed
anyway at the end of the night the guys
go to tip tip me out i'm like wow i'm
going to make
i don't know you know i'm going to well
rob you you bartend what do you think i
i a barbecue's going to make new york
city
same yeah
24 hours of oh my god
as a bar back on the upper west side
when i would work just like the one
night shift on a saturday i'd come home
with four 400 bucks for 500 bucks yeah
as a bar back
because the bartenders were making
right yeah i made i think they gave me
50 dollars
oh my god i was so
furious i was like
like tears in my eyes furious you know
but i didn't say anything at the time
but i was just like okay and i'm going
home on the subway and it's like
thinking about like what am i gonna do
and then i was like all right here's
what i'm gonna do i'm gonna go back up
there i'm gonna throw a brick through
the glass window you're gonna take it
out on the entire organization yeah
instead i just never went back to work
there i just was like all right i'm done
and i i didn't call to quit i just never
showed up again good and then i started
waiting tables at the cornelia street
cafe and i was very bad you know people
i would come to the table i'm like you
had the fish they were like no i ordered
the chicken i'll be right back i'm gonna
go to the kitchen uh very terrible at
that and then very shortly after that
did a
like a monologue showcase and i got a
commercial agent
uh along with a regular agent that i'd
gotten up at williamstown and just
started getting like foot locker
commercials and little things and what i
wouldn't give to to see a video of that
monologue
oh what i wouldn't give it was good mom
it was eric bergozzi i feel like you
nailed it oh yeah you think do you think
if you watched it now you would
there's i did some performances in
college that i where i was like i was
amazing
and no i think it was great and watched
them like because they they have those
in the in the at the library that you
can you can check out
and i watched a couple of my
performances and i was like oh no
i was i think it was good no it was
funny because i think that was the main
thing about it like all those people
took it very seriously and ryan was kind
of funny it's like this guy who walks up
to a guy and is like excuse me hey i'm
sorry i couldn't have noticed your shoes
there you know and slowly begins to
steal the person's shoes and it's a very
funny monologue it's like you mind if i
try those on
and uh you know it would get big laughs
well here's some good you know i'm
always being asked by young actors who
you know pull me like how do you what
can i do to like break into the industry
i will say
that because i did the same thing when
we did our showcases in college
in front of managers and agents and and
casting directors or whatever everybody
wanted to be serious and just use these
like very serious emotional scenes and i
was like
i bet you
people are so sick of that like and so i
did two funny scenes yeah
and got an agent and manager like
instantly and i do think so if my advice
to you young actor if you uh get into a
showcase
be the funny one be the enter to
entertain them because no one else
thinks everyone else thinks like i have
to give an oscar-worthy performance in
this and it's just [ __ ] boring and
sad yeah think about it you're the
whoever's in there
you know a commercial agent or whatever
a regular agent and is watching
monologue after monologue they're
probably saying okay who has a beautiful
face and i know can work so that's
that's the shitty side of it
and then they're saying who's an
interesting type that will that will pop
and then
if you're funny
and you get laughs in the room by the
way you'll know like if you're not funny
and you're doing your monologue and
you're getting crickets well i'll find
out well then you know but if you're if
you can make a room full of people laugh
then suddenly someone says well there's
that person has an ability that i can
sell so that
was that yeah yeah
rob what was the shittiest job that you
had to do uh as a struggling actor to be
uh
shittiest job well i mean
i don't know that i had shitty jobs i
just had a series of
waiting tables and and bar backing and
things how did you how did you become an
actor tell us that's what i mean i know
but like television i don't recall how
like how did you
get it was a model rob was never a model
rob wasn't well he tried to be no he
didn't model search america they were
looking for people who it was it was
actors and models okay and i fell into
our my friend chris backus for example
fell into the category chris bacchus has
got beautiful play on this podcast
he's working all the time but he was my
friend and he was uh he's very clearly a
model but they were also looking for
actors like commercial actors
and i the truth of the matter is it was
because i was 21 years old and i looked
like i was 15. yeah you were like i can
play little tiny babies yes which we've
talked about i think we've talked about
so they're like he's a boy model no so
they were like he can work we can work
him like an animal and he can be on a
set for 13 14 hours as opposed to a 15
year old man so i started doing
commercials that right and then and then
i would do but i didn't get i didn't get
as many as you did and i didn't get them
as quickly you guys got a good look up
on youtube rob's uh anti-smoking uh
commercial from when he was how old were
you when you shot that 19 no no i was 20
i mean i was at least 21. you look you
look 13 years 13. but how did wait i'm
sorry how did you get in front of those
people how did you get yeah so there was
this there was this um organization
called model search america which was
which which would like travel around the
country and and they took an ad out in
the newspaper looking for beautiful
looking for looking looking for
beautiful people and then looking for
seriously like looking looking for
character-ish type people and they were
like actors models whatever and at first
i thought oh this is like a scam and
then you look it up and there was like
i'm gonna get you're like i'm gonna get
riddled for sure it's definitely gonna
get diddled and so you go to this open
call and i went to this open call and
this was in philly and then they were
like yeah come back
and then you come back and you go to
this
this like event and then you
wind up like talking to all of these
agents and they basically bring you into
like the modeling agents and then they
were like
no not you and then
then the commercial agents were like oh
you have an interesting look how old are
you and then once they found out how old
i was and that i could work as a chi
work as an adult that looked like a
child i i signed with one of the biggest
commercial agents in new york which was
s e m and m
right
back to that we're back to that yeah and
then again and then i started work and
then i started uh well i got a book to
commercial and then i was like i'm going
to move to new york and then i didn't
work for two years now
two-part question um
how many times did you get diddled and
uh the other part of the question is did
you just push past it or or did you have
to explain to them i'm not actually what
you want because i'm 23 years old and
then they were like oh well that you
just you ruined it there's a lot maybe
that's that's the thing there's a lot of
disappointment because it's like you're
not breaking the law right now oh
right that they're like oh i'm ruining
your life and i'm like no no i've
already no i'm already ruined guy i'm
52. yeah
i've grown
i was ruined years ago right yeah i ruin
other kids um what did you uh
did you
were
auditioning consistently were you
auditioning consistently yeah like well
i would see all of you guys at the same
auditions i just wasn't getting those
jobs the commercial auditions too like
some of those jobs none of us were
getting because they were big movies and
yeah we were unknown people but like
but like the commercials they were
constantly
casting they were and i just wasn't i
just wasn't getting them you know like
people have like
certain
things that they want
yeah and you want wasn't it i wasn't it
you weren't looked too young to be in
the beer commercial well no then once i
then got old enough to look
about 18
then they were like well there's lots of
you right
and that was that you know i did my i
did my my lawn order and i did my i did
all the the new york stuff
yeah then that runs out and then you
moved to los angeles glenn did you never
do a lawn order
i never got i never even auditioned for
law and order probably one of the only
actors in the universe who lived in new
york and never did law and order no that
i think the first on-camera gig i did
was rescue me oh no not rescue me sorry
um uh what was dennis leary's show
before that the
oh god what was the name of that show
remember where i oh
yeah well that was out here
no that was in new york oh it was that
was in new york the job yep that that's
the show megan pulled it up the job
uh it was pretty good shows i had like a
half hour drama comedy about about cops
uh well it was a comedy but it was it
took place in a police squadron anyway
uh that was my first on-camera gig
and then uh
yeah and then i did like a abc movie
of the week called monday night mayhem
where i played dick eversole yes i
remember that too yeah yeah gabersol oh
man wow you know it was funny because i
i also looked very young not as young as
you did but i had kind of a babyish face
and i i looked pretty young and um but i
already had like massive amounts of
chest hair
like an obscene amount of chest hair uh
for for some for the didn't match the
face at all i was like it was like tom
selleck level chest hair on the face of
like a somebody who looks like he's 18
years old
and
uh so i booked this deck dick abersol
role and there was a scene where i was
supposed to be sitting and we were me
and um
[Music]
oh god what was that actress john uh
heard
not hurt but heard
rest in peace
uh john hurd and i were supposed to be
at a golf course sitting in these like
lounging chairs like looking over the
golf course smoking cigars and watching
people play golf and having this very
serious uh conversation about about
football
and when i showed up on the day to shoot
that scene um they were like they showed
me my to my dressing room and
uh i go in there they're like go ahead
and get into wardrobe and then we'll get
you into hair and makeup and i was like
great so i i open the closet they're
like yeah your wardrobes in the cloth
open the closet
it's just a little teeny tiny pair of
shorts like a pair of like uh
my bathing suit and i was like
uh
uh
on a golf course like what's going on i
pulled the id aside and i was like what
is this
why am i wearing a bathing suit on a
golf course and i'm like oh they changed
it they changed it you're gonna be in a
hot tub now
and what i didn't want to say because i
was super embarrassed about is i was
like i have so much chest hair and i
just don't want to show it and i hadn't
yeah oh i was so self-conscious about it
because i was like i want you know i i
wanted to be able to play young men and
yet i had that i had the torso of like a
40 year old man in the face of an 18
year old and it just didn't mat
and i i remember i went to the hair and
makeup trailer and i was like hey do you
guys have scissors and i [ __ ] like
tried to trim
the top part because i knew it was only
the top part of my chest hair that would
show and then i and then we got in the
hot tub and i dipped down as low as i
could get only trim the top i see what
you're going you're going to the
shoulders i know what you're going for
but when you took your shirt off was it
just the top of your chest hair that was
trimmed and then the lower half was full
bush yes
full bush yeah but that's because i was
new i knew it was going to be in a hot
tub so only a certain amount of it was
going to show and that was the and i
didn't have time yeah i honestly didn't
have time to do the thing so we're
changing the block in here you guys are
going to be standing
[Laughter]
yeah that would have been yeah yeah now
you're going to be standing outside but
like i tried to get as low in that hot
tub as i possibly could oh so like guys
i was so self-conscious about it i
really was of course sure that how
[ __ ] up that is that they're like oh
by the way now uh yeah it used to be in
the screen okay yeah and all of a sudden
you're gonna be half naked no no yeah
[ __ ] you do that yeah but i didn't know
i didn't know [ __ ] you at the time i
just of course you know well
that's part of the that isn't that part
of the problem it's like nobody knows
[ __ ] nobody has the confidence to say
[ __ ] you because they think they're
going to get fired which by the way you
might have i might have yeah you
definitely would have yeah back then
back then yeah probably yeah
oh guys
well i'm bored uh are you bored well
yeah i mean i love you guys but um
you're sick of it yeah and i think that
the audience has had enough and let's do
the next one tomorrow yeah guys we did
it
we did it we did it
the end